hey everyone persia here and we've
rounded up more
community clips to celebrate the airship
they're all going to be among us if you
want to figure out how you can submit
your own clips then go ahead and leave a
like
subscribe and stay tuned to the end of
the video
i don't want to do it i don't want to do
it
but i got to do oh it's but dicey solved
it
okay okay
[Music]
go to the kitchen i want to see what you
can do out here can you actually cook
use what you can
you could legit make a sandwich oh wait
hold up
okay all right wait bring that back down
okay
fine i feel like this that spongebob
episode bear
please don't don't ring the alarm before
i finish my sandwich
tomato okay wait hold up
okay and then oh no
they ain't even let me finish my damn
sandwich man like
[Music]
it's pretty unlucky though if you die
straight off them
oh
you get the [ __ ]
[Music]
wait
you're about to see some names just
light up
red ten
nine eight seven
six five
four three two
um wait i wanted to kill me i wanted to
use it
that's selfish kill me
give me give me
oh my god
oh my god steve you are such a jerk
[Music]
koji
koji koji koji koji why are you doing
this man
i'm so sorry dude
[Music]
[Music]
showers okay you know what this is how
much i trust lud that he's not imposter
i will literally follow him because
i can just tell when people are crew
i can tell he like his voice is so
like passionate and edison is so
opposite he's so edison is so um
oh jesus i'm gonna lose him i'm gonna
lose him
here's more reason to believe he's he's
clear he likes to go
off and he doesn't kill me
coffee stay with me oh my god are you an
imposter are you an imposter
that movement are you just are you just
that good at towels
hopefully please stay with me please
coffee i don't want to die
please don't be an imposter of all the
times to be an imposter don't be one
this time
please oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god i'm going to clear you
happy i'm going to clear you
we're going to get a clear on how few
this is the greatest play actually it's
actually the greatest play you know why
this is the greatest play
we're going to clear hafu right we're
going to clear for a double kill
or whatever and and now she's not sus
from the ellen thing
it's like if you think about it it's
genius
how could you
oh my god bro you serious
seem right i guess unreal
did junk say now i get to kill
is junk gotta go in here all right i'm
gonna
we're gonna do our task why am i not
brown
all right we're going to go develop some
codes
we're going to develop some codes
we're doing developing some code turn
the lights off
[Music]
what is he doing i don't even know who
my killer
is
[Music]
junk unfortunately you are not me
[Music]
why was he or was he muted he should not
have been muted
[Music]
why would steve jump in there
[Music]
welcome
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
christmas carsbury freedom
defender
that's a wrap on our clips of the week
but if you want to submit your own clip
for next week then make sure you tag me
and gamespot on twitter
at persia underscore xo and at gamespot
thank you guys so much for watching and
we will catch you next time
peace
you